[Music]
we made
I'm not positive but I think I'm
supposed to steal second beat concertina
and Selena Minogue they call themselves
death he's in drag because it's faster
than using your hands to spell out gay
deaf Latinas drag queens these gals take
four boxes off the old quota list with
no sense of hearing
apparently they developed a heightened
sense of style they look like beautiful
Brazilian parade floats they're popular
YouTube channel brings attention to the
deaf community while also poking fun
it's basically what I do for the
shithead community some people say God
smited them for their alternative
lifestyles but I think it was just his
way of hooking them up with free bose
noise-canceling headphones deaf people
are known for their sense of humor
there's a reason it's not called blind
Comedy Jam there are only 1 million deaf
people in America but if they all got
together to march in Washington they're
chanting would make everyone
uncomfortable which would lead to change
hearing loss is barely a handicap
nowadays thanks to texting
I'd love to never hear my family maybe
then I'd be able to make it through a
Thanksgiving without wanting to kill
myself cos Davina and Celina are the
perfect women they don't talk and they
have penises that's why I drag those
Queens to Hollywood metaphorically of
course
for this week's ce-web-rity profile
[Applause]
[Music]
gennadiy follow oficial de las personas
que look with me it's love it's raining